a class has 25 students let's begin just
by jotting down the important
information okay 25 students in total
19 of them study at least
one of art and music 19 of them
study at least one okay so if i write
that down
19 they study at least one
that is art or music
or art and music do you agree with that
okay there's only one
category of student that's not included
in that 19
right so they study
art or music sorry i should put a slash
or art and music right which
group of students is left out by that
the ones that don't study either does
that make sense so immediately and we're
going to put this onto our diagram in a
second you can see it there right
immediately i can make an inference so
even though i'm not all the way through
the question i'm going to jot down now
from here right therefore 6 study
neither is that ok tracking along so far
great 19 of them study at least one
16 of them study at most
one which is a really weird way of
saying it by the way at most
one okay let's now let's think about
this and i'm going to just put my hand
up and say actually when i first read
this question
i completely misread that i was like at
most one what does that include
now you know how i said here we've got
an exhaustive list of everyone included
in the 19. do you agree
people study art people study music
people who study both
so let's think about who is included in
this group
of 16
would they be included in this group if
they studied art
yes yes should they study
art they would be in this group if they
just studied music
would they be in this group yes they
would
we know that they won't be included if
they study
both right because at most one but
there's one other group that's included
in here have a think about it it says
at most one so if i'm a student who
doesn't study either of these
i study zero of them does that make
sense
and zero is included in at
most one at most means everything and
below does that make sense
i'll say that again right at most
includes either
or neither that's
weird right i think that's the curveball
in the question
okay so so we've got this right
and then two it says two students are
chosen at random from the class okay so
that doesn't tell us anything about that
so we're ready now to start to construct
this venn diagram maybe the numbers are
starting to make sense to you okay so
hopefully you drew a box of some kind if
you only drew circles you're in trouble
because you couldn't represent this
group here does that make sense so this
is our class
i've got an art circle and a music
circle let's call that a
and m so i know that in this big
rectangle it's going to add up to 25 so
that i know
okay which of these other numbers can i
immediately put on the diagram
six six right where does it go six on
the outside yeah it's
somewhere around here okay i'll put in
the bottom right corner at ishan's
suggestion okay so if that's six
i then have to say um i've got one two
three other spots
that i've got to fill in okay what do i
put there now this is actually again
another curveball in the question i
actually don't know and i will never
know there is not enough information in
the question
to know what either of these numbers is
okay
so i'm just going to put that right out
there if you saw if you started to put
numbers in there you were
guessing basically but this number in
here i'm just going to call it z
this number i can work out question or
thought
i just i just realized how because when
you remove
the one the neither from the aha yes
yes you get ten yep which is the people
that do only a
or m very good yes okay so that means
both are going to have to be nine
uh okay so let's get there right
nineteen minutes okay so let's let's get
let's see if we can get there okay so
what i've got right now what i've got
right now
is that i've got to try and work out
i've
dealt with this six right
and now i have to sort of do something
with these two here do you agree with
that i've got to try and fit them
together in some way
okay but to do that i've got to get
this group here which i just told you
you'll never know you don't have enough
information to know just art
and just music is it okay
sorry is that cool right uh well i'm not
gonna call it a z-score because that's a
different thing but this
number zed oh right it's just a letter i
mean i could have called it out for a
bit or whatever okay
so how i'm gonna work this out right
well 16
16 are art
or music or neither do you agree with
that that's just art just music
or neither so i can say that that 16 is
x plus y plus six do you agree with that
is that okay there's the only art the
only music and then the neither
so that tells me if i subtract six from
both sides x plus y is
10 right so this here
x plus y is 10 that's that's what i put
i think i even chose those letters right
x plus y equals 10.
i don't know if it's like 3 7 or 5 5 or
1 9
no idea not enough information in the
question okay
but there is enough information for me
to then go from this back up to this guy
right do you see that so i've now
accounted for
the only art students and the only music
students which means that the only group
left over within that 19 is the art
and music students the one who do both
okay so therefore i can say
up here that tan
plus zed do you agree there's the
10 here and then the z that should give
me 19. is that okay
so that is where in my diagram i then
say oh this
is this is nine who study both is that
okay
now i actually think it's very sneaky um
if if i were you if you want to make
this adjustment on your piece of paper
i think 16 part a the one we just did i
think it should be worth two marks and i
think part b
should be worth one just a personal
opinion not that matters we're not
measuring or anything like that but if
you wanted to there's a lot of work
doing there
well nessa didn't write this paper okay
so then part b kind of follows from
there
two students get selected at random do
you remember that
find the probability that both students
chosen study exactly one of art music so
how do i work this out what's the
fraction that leads
to this probability equals what do you
think about
a goes in say it again
[Music]
i use the notation okay you can use the
notation so i'm looking for two
different things right
i'm looking for first student
is art and music right so um
art or music that's the first student
and then you're looking for
another one right so these are two
different students
okay student one and student two let's
call them okay
now i've got to work out the probability
of one and then do i add or do i
multiply it to the probability of the
other well
if it's a and b it's the independent
let's have a think about this right now
i think the easiest way to understand
this is
i need both of these things to happen
right they both have to happen i've got
to
pick a student one and a student too and
you can hear it in the way i say it
and right it's like well that means i've
got to multiply they've got to be
included together
okay so therefore what's the probability
of the first student
studying just one of them have a look
how many students do study
just one
have a look it's going to be it's going
to be the x and the y groups right
they study either art or music so that
means there's 10 of them
do you agree and then i say well i'm
dividing by however many students there
are
in total which is 25 right
that's the first student and then i want
the other student to be in that same
group right but there aren't 10 of them
anymore because i just
chose one how many left
are you trolling me max there were 10
before i've chosen one
successfully so there are nine left but
there are also no longer 25 students in
the whole group to choose from right
so 24. so this gives you nine out of
from memory
600 which should simplify to
um is that right yeah three out of
five did i get that right
no no wait no it's 90. it's not i'm
missing a zero that's
that's three out of 20. is that okay
okay